[Musique]
c'est en musique au rythme du maloya que
s'élèvent fête les 10 ans de leur
collège un établissement construit en
2008 sur la commune de saint benoît qui
compte aujourd'hui 700 19 collégiens
déjà on va faire des affiches donc avec
un certain groupe le groupe angel et
ensuite on va faire un défilé de
vêtements en papier
ah oui aussi le collège guy-môquet
entamé une démarche de végétalisation de
ces espaces un travail mené avec les
adjoints techniques territoriaux de
l'établissement et collégiens ont reçu
cette année pour leur démarche de
développement durable
le label national de l'éco collège le
département joue pleinement son vol
s'investit aux côtés de l'équipe
éducative pour que nos enfants puissent
connaître bien-être et travailler dans
de très bonnes conditions c'est ça
l'important port c'est que notre
jeunesse puisse demain peut se dire
belle
je ce collège j'étais et aujourd'hui je
suis devenu pour eux mêmes des acteurs
je cherchais une activité d'une belle
réussite à travers aussi ce passage dans
ce collège
[Musique]
m